we begin the day with a 40-mile long
convoy of russian military might at the
door of the ukrainian capital satellite
images show russian forces advancing
towards kiev and it comes as the russian
defense ministry today warned residents
to leave their homes while they still
can moscow saying that it is planning to
launch air strikes on the city now it
has been almost one week since the
russian invasion began in that time the
u.n says more than 660
000 refugees have fled ukraine at least
136 civilians have been killed and that
includes 13 children
a day after signing an official request
for ukraine to join the european union
ukraine's president vladimir zelinski
today called on european leaders to
prove that they are with the people of
ukraine
the impact of his message so strong that
it can even be heard in the voice of the
translator
take a listen
[Music]
just for our land
and for our freedom
equal members
of
europe i believe that
today
are showing everybody that's exactly
what we are
so do prove that you are with us
do prove
and light will win over
darkness
we want to pull in our correspondent now
nick connolly he joins us from western
ukraine good evening to you
nick we we've got reports that up to
eight
leaders
of eu member states
have come out in support of zielinski's
call for immediate eu membership
what are you hearing and tell me what
would that mean
in the immediate term for the people of
ukraine
well brent it would mean hope
given that you know one of the reasons
we're here is at least this is what
russia says is to stop
ukraine joining nato that's is one of
the stated goals of uh russia's campaign
although most ukrainians would say it's
more about ukraine ukraine being brought
back to russia's sphere of influence as
it sees it but in its constitution
ukraine says it wants to move west it
wants to join nato and it wants to move
the eu
there's the potential there that eu
membership would mean being part of a
big western family would mean support
would mean feeling seen and heard
without the same security implications
and the same
resistance from moscow to that
membership we heard uh today from
putin's spokesman who said that eu
membership was not a threat to russia
and was not something that russia
objected to
i'm not sure that's quite
true i think russia would want to
continue to influence this country more
than it would be able to in the case of
eu membership but it's certainly less of
a kind of hot potato and that seemingly
could be a way out of this crisis that
ukraine like finland could be in the eu
but not in nato
is there any discussion nick of the fact
that
ukraine has had the past eight years to
prepare itself for possible eu
membership and many analysts would say
when you look at the rampant corruption
for example that the country has wasted
that time is anyone saying anything like
that at the moment
obviously there are lots of missed
opportunities here but lots of
ukrainians would ask how much further
romania and bulgaria have got and had
they not had a real perspective of
joining the eu where would they be now
had they like ukraine being kept outside
would they be any further than ukraine
ukraine has made huge strides albeit
maybe from a place that was further
behind the rest of europe than most
other countries in this part of the
world partly also because it had a very
chaotic 90s and also partly because of
that lack of a perspective
most ukrainians didn't want to be part
of the russian influence but they were
never given any thing to work towards by
the west and so they were kind of
hanging in the air and that's one of the
things lots of ukrainians were saying we
tried being neutral we tried being
outside of all blocks in the 90s when we
were not russia but we were also not
trying to join western clubs and in the
end we gave they even gave up their
nuclear weapons return for security
guarantees which didn't stop russia
taking crimea which didn't stop russia
fermenting that separatist movement in
the east and they say we are just too
big to be hanging in the air as some
kind of neutral country we are not
finland we're not
we're not switzerland we need some kind
of harbor in this region yeah it's a
huge country 40 million people
russian forces they have been shelling
civilian areas in the city of kharkiv
that is ukraine's second biggest city it
is also a city that has a
russian-speaking
majority close cultural ties to russia
so what does it tell us nick about
the the kremlin
that it is willing to bomb a city like
kharkiv
it tells us the kremlin doesn't care
about public opinion and it doesn't care
about soft power i think part of this
crisis is all about russia's lack of
soft power russia does not have a model
that is attractive to middle-class
citizens he has a model that's
attractive to kleptocracies in central
asia
but it doesn't have any story of where
development goes apart from russian
strength it doesn't have any values
unlike the soviet union that it can use
to bind
allies to itself it's a country largely
without allies or if they do have allies
it tends to be the kind of ruling elites
in places like uh tajikistan but for a
country like ukraine it has europe on
its doorstep that russian model just
isn't attractive and so russia is now
trying to make up for that lack of soft
power with force and the fact that
they're willing to bomb the city when
they're always talking about this you
know brother brother nations between
ukraine and russia obviously you know
puts paid to all those that that talk
from moscow so if you've got bombs
coming down air strikes in eastern
ukraine with their russian brothers
what what are people what must people
then in western ukraine
be
thinking and be worried about i mean
what will the russians do to them
well there is even the theory that
actually uh vladimir putin would even be
happiest if the western part of ukraine
kind of was i don't know
taken in by the polls or became
independent and didn't basically kind of
as the russians would see it
infect the minds of ukrainians and kiev
and kharkiv and nepro with the idea of
the european feature future lots of the
kind of ideological outriders of the
kremlin keep talking about the fact that
it would actually be better for russia
if places like lev uh just went went
their way and became part of bigger
europe and then they could just get on
with basically assimilating uh places in
central and eastern ukraine
dw's nick connolly reporting tonight
from western ukraine as always nick
excellent reporting
stay safe thank you